I had a lot of toxins on my testing, does that correlate to my genetic testing?
Sometimes it does, I don't know who asked this question, so we could look and see if it did.
And how would it correlate? So that's a question. How would
my body harmering a lot of toxins correlate to genetic testing? So remember,
how do you, okay, if you ran a toxicity test and you had a lot of toxins, what does that tell you?
It tells you either A, you were exposed to an enormous amount of toxins and
let's pretend you had a perfectly healthy liver and you had no genetic defects in your detoxification
pathways and you had no other damage to liver cells and you had great glutathione production and
SOD and other oxidative pathways were perfectly functioning, but it was solely because of
the rate of toxicity, the level of toxicity that you were exposed to at any given time
that overwhelmed your liver's ability to get rid of it at that given time. So it was
shunted into your tissues and stored in your cells and at your extremely toxic because of that
one incidence or ten incidence or daily incidence of exposure. So you're working in it. Okay,
here's a perfect example. I had a gentleman, this was years ago, he had aluminum toxicity,
when you ran heavy metal testing on him, his aluminum was off the chart. It's like, okay,
what's going on? He was having all these brain fog issues and dementia issues and he was
much too early in his life, he was in his early 50s. Well, turns out he actually
what he did is he worked for Delta Airlines and he drilled hole that he says all I do is drill holes
in aluminum all day long. That's what I do. He was a mechanic and did repairs on plates
and then they were aluminum and he was drilling holes and of course you're drilling holes,
you're gasifying some of the solid and he was breathing it in. So he was basically poisoning
himself and he was, so this was going to be in a worker's cub, click case and he ended up going to
Mayo and getting EDTA, uh, uh, interview this to help pull this out of his body and he had changed
jobs. So it was because of his daily exposure to toxins that had really maybe little to do with his
liver of health. Maybe that's always a part. Nobody has this perfect liver, nobody has a perfect
genetics. Um, but it had much less to do with that and much more to do with his level and rate of
toxic exposure. So that is the way we get toxic, but another way we get toxic is we might have just,
we might be exposed to maybe a lower level of toxins, but we have issues with our liver, maybe
partly genetic and partly environmental because we've damaged our liver in other ways. So we're
a considered what will be considered a slow detox or see, just don't get rid of things that
your partner does. Maybe your, your friend does and you are exposed to, say, level of toxins and
you just, and your liver just can handle less. So it gets stays in your system and gets shut into
your tissues and into the cells and can cause cancer and all sorts of problems. So yes, you're the
lots of toxins that you might have can directly correlate to genetic issues with detoxification pathways.
We'll be looking at cytochrome P450 pathways, P1 pathways and AT pathways,
glutathio pathways, SOD pathways, all those kind of things that are part of your whole detoxification
system.